E
STATE DEPARTMENT.
RICH, THANKS.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, WE ARE
LEARNING NEW DETAILS ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN CYBER GANG SUSPECTED OF
SHUTTING DOWN A MAJOR MEAT
PROCESSOR THIS WEEK AND STAGING
OTHER ATTACKS IN RECENT PAST.
THERE IS ALSO A DEBATE TONIGHT
ABOUT WHETHER PRIVATE BUSINESSES
OR THE GOVERNMENT ARE MOST
RESPONSE CYBIL FOR FAILING TO DO
ENOUGH TO PREVENT THEM.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN REPORTS TONIGHT
FROM THE PENTAGON.
GOOD EVENING, JENNIFER.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SENT
GUIDANCE TO U.S. ATTORNEYS
OFFICES ACROSS THE COUNTRY TODAY
ELEVATING INVESTIGATIONS OF
RANSOMWARE ATTACKS TO THE SAME
PRIORITY AS FIGHTING TERRORISM.
THESE INVESTIGATIONS WILL NOW BE
CENTRALLY COORDINATED WITH A NEW
TASK FORCE IN WASHINGTON.
>> U.S. LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYS THE
RUSSIAN LINKED CYBER GANG KNOWN
AS.
>> EVIL IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ATTACK.
THE GROUP MADE ITS PRESENCE FELT
IN 2020 RELEASING 2.4
GIG-A-BYTES OF LADY GAGA LEGAL
DOCUMENTS.
IT CARRIED OUT ATTACK ON APPLE
SUPPLIER DEMANDING $50 MILLION.
TODAY THE WHITE HOUSE TRIED TO
SHIFT THE BLAME TO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
>> BUSINESS LEADERS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO STRENGTHEN
THEIR CYBER DEFENSES, TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND OUR
ECONOMY.
>> DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER ANN NEWBURGHER ISSUED A
MEMO OUTLINING HOW COMPANIES CAN
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM WHAT ARE
USUALLY SIMPLE SPEAR FISHING
EMAILS.
QUOTE, THERE ARE IMMEDIATE STEPS
CAN YOU TAKE TO PROTECT YOURSELF
AS WELL AS THE CUSTOMERS AND THE
BROADER ECONOMY.
THE NATION'S TOP CYBER EXPERT
SAY THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS NOT
DONE ENOUGH TO DETER THESE
ATTACKS.
>> THESE ARE CRIMINAL GROUPS
OPERATING INDEPENDENTLY SEEKING
TO MAKE MONEY BUT THEY ARE GIVEN
SANCTUARY AND PROTECTION BY THE
RUSSIAN STATE.
WE ARE ONLY SEEING THE ONES THAT
MAKE IT INTO THE PUBLIC EYE.
THERE'S HUNDREDS, IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF THESE ATTACKS EVERY
YEAR.
>> JBS SAID IT'S ON SCHEDULE TO
RESUME PRODUCTION AT ALL OF
THEIR MEAT-PACKING FACILITIES
TODAY.
IT'S NOT CLEAR IF THE COMPANY
PAID A RANSOM.
COLONIAL PIPELINE RECENTLY PAID
A $4.4 MILLION RANSOM TO ANOTHER
GROUP OF RUSSIAN CYBER
CRIMINALS.
JAMES LEWIS SAYS THE LAST TWO
ADMINISTRATIONS AND THE CURRENT
ONE HAVE BEEN TOO CAUTIOUS IN
THEIR RESPONSE.
>> THAT'S PART OF WHY THE
RUSSIANS THINK WHY SHOULD I
STOP?
I'M MAKING A LOT OF MONEY AND
THE AMERICANS AREN'T GOING TO DO
ANYTHING.
WE NEED TO MAKE A MOVE.
PUTIN JUST ISN'T AFRAID OF US
AND THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS TO CHANGE.
>> LEWIS SAYS THE TIMING OF THE
LATEST CYBERATTACKS SO CLOSE TO
THE SUMMIT BETWEEN PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND PUTIN IS SURPRISING.
HISTORICALLY, HE SAID THERE HAS
BEEN A CEASE-FIRE IN THE WEEKS
LEADING UP TO MEETINGS LIKE
THIS.
>> TODAY RUSSIA ANNOUNCED IT IS
DITCHING THE U.S. DOLLAR AS PART
OF ITS SOVEREIGN WEALTH FUND
KNOWING THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
COULD IMPOSE NEW SANCTIONS.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SEE CEASE
TWO INTERNET DOMAINS THIS WEEK
USED IN SPEAR PHISHING ATTACKS
USED IN EMAIL COMMUNICATION